[Musique]
l'organisme sans filtre podcast jpf
quant à moi de dôme plan
aujourd'hui on reçoit gabriel marion
quétaine youtube euse trans qui défie
limites en fait qui nous informe un peu
ce que les réalités d'être une personne
transsexuelle
et si jamais vous nous écoutez vous
aimez ça peut laisser des commentaires
pour participer à la discussion on aime
se voulait on aime se répondre aux
commentaires
puis aussi vous abonner à la chaîne pour
rester à l'affût des podcasts allez
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation et plaisir moi quand je
suis sorti d'occupation double je me
suis connecté par hasard sur le compte
youtube de ma blonde qui t'était danser
les vidéos par les favoris les vidéos
qui compte en premier je les écoutais
brièvement au début puis quand qu'on a
décidé de faire le podcast puis qu'on
essayait de penser un peu à qui on
voulait inviter pour avoir des personnes
intéressantes aux podcasts sont tout
pensé à toi grâce que je pense que tu tu
représente une réalité connue et méconnu
exact c'est sur lt méconnu puis aussi
as-tu fait avec tellement de deux
nationalités d'assurance qui se serait
une discussion vraiment intéressante à
voir avec toi autour de autour de tout
enfant
en finalité est la seule la farce au
québec pas très long mais il y en a
d'autres qui font un peu plus comme
hello kitty mince mais il y en a tant
qu'ils font une que je connais bien qui
s'appelle kate le sort qui va le fait
pas autant je pense que tu es jeudi à
peut-être pas vécu autant de trucs à
documenter que je les fais métissé une
transe qui affiche est quand même
surtout sinon québec je pense pas qu'on
ait d'autres de web lé même en réalité
je suis pourtant l'extérieur du web je
sais pas non plus c'est que c'est quand
même unique dans ton corps parce que
quand tu as commencé à détailler
youtuber a fait 1 pi 7 cette pression-là
ces faits devant les yeux des gens pis
ça c'est unique c'est une expérience qui
dure est
montagnes russes pour toi là vraiment
mais je te dirais que c'est en drift
super important pour moi de l'affiché
comme ça mais en même temps j'ai quand
même pris un certain recul avant de
faire comme un coming out
si j'avais commencé ma transition sans
le dire à personne guité les gens
remarquer des petits changements à
battiston encore gabriel jamal puis
comme renoir manet j'ai arrêté de faire
des vidéos comme tête un ou deux mois
maximum sur jiwa rêveur fait que je
trouvais ça vraiment important pour tout
le monde puis autant pour moi aussi de
mon triste documenté sur mais en même
temps c'est comme tu dis mon teint gris
mais je te dirais que ça tellement et
épouse j'ai eu aucun commentaire négatif
quand je fais des vêtements vidéo de
coming out pas que pour moi ça a été une
grosse validation c'est pas avec le fait
de le faire dans l'oeil du public salue
comme et des conditionnements vraiment
on n'a rien vraiment pour moi c'est ce
qui m'a aidé dans la vie de comprendre
qui j'étais vraiment c'était youtube je
trouve ce thème important de le partager
puis d'être aussi un exemple ouais mais
je pense que tu te fais exactement ce
jeu persuadé que beaucoup de personnes
qui se cherche qui qui voit-on exemple
puis qu'ils doivent se sentir beaucoup
mieux eux mêmes problèmes encore soit
des commentaires comme ça sur la tête
extrêmement gratifiant c'est très
gratifiant mais ça c'est ce que ça mais
quand même un gros poids sur les épaules
parce que je suis comme une image
importante pour quelqu'un infecté il
faut quand même que le genre mais non
monsieur c sipa gratuit je trouve ça
super important aussi que les gens me
dis pas que les amas le disney de savoir
que j'allais des personnes je trouve ça
vraiment pas parce qu'elle n'est plus
compensée par une crise extrêmement mais
il y en a beaucoup qui savent justement
pas comme un parcours aller ou que
beaucoup de personnes que la famille
sont pas d'accord avec ça ils savent pas
quel cheminement fait qu'on a quand même
beaucoup de tirs est le même
ce à quoi ça commence lui à sortir un
peu plus les gens commencent à être plus
à l'aise ou qui sont plus mais ce que du
moins ça pour les gens qui sont pas
transmet qui t'écoute
c'est extrêmement informatif fit voter
la première personne trans que je
rencontre dans ma vie je le dis pis des
vidéos j'ai écouté pour pour m'informer
pouvoir être informés sur le sujet j'ai
appris énormément puis justement t-il
beaucoup de préjugés ou bâti des
difficultés je pense les personnes trans
peuvent vivre parce que c'était somme
toute
ou peut-être parce qu'on pense somme
toute fort je pense comme la société qui
fait que quand tu es quand il tombe face
à face avec une personne trans peu resté
surpris peut-être parce que tu n'as
jamais vu
oui cet envoi sur internet à savoir quoi
dire qu'on peut consulter les gens non
plus pas l'iphone puis je pense entre
autre vidéo avec quelques routiers sur
les dix questions
ouais mais des fois qu'ils étaient
vraiment des inconnus
nadja c'est encore une job de vie
publique vraiment des personnes qui ont
juste aucun filtre sont vraiment changé
mais c'est celle avec qui sait vraiment
ce qu'ils pensent trop réac mais c'est
sûr que ça rend un peu mal à l'aise
c'est que sa vie personnelle
terracotta may et août ont quitté risque
de tuer quand même parce que tout le
monde
question étrangers
j'espère que chez nous et je pense que
celle chalada blanc de deux projets
maquillage et un autre sphère
[Rires]
je crois que tient on parle on parle de
la transphobie un petit peu plus dans la
société et puis de l'acceptation moi je
crois que ça sa part que je vois sur ne
trompe d'une de mauvaises informations
ont peut-être d'ignorance beaucoup
d'ignorants beaucoup de yolande et c'est
aussi une mauvaise information mais
beaucoup d'ignorance de juste je pense
que les gens il suffit trop à des
stéréotypes probablement puis faut que
tout le monde fait une idée de ce que
c'est mais ces personnes vraiment si ce
que ca - de vie je pense c'est vraiment
beaucoup d'ignorance c'est aussi ce que
si je pense que c'est peu différent pour
ces exemples certainement vont avoir une
chirurgie donnons bien de vivre ce fait
ils varient d'une personne à l'autre
fait que c'est dur ça va exactement
qu'est ce que c'est aussi c'est sûr
c'est ce que pour chaque personne le
parcours est différent il y en a pour
qui il ya des choses qui sont
importantes pour d'autres c'est lipow
c'est comme un peu comment je pourrais
tu es sûr c'est vraiment juste c'est
pour le personnel à bakou vraiment
personnel puis tu peux pas juger une
personne parce qu'elle n'est pas faite
téléchirurgie puisque l'autre le film
savait pas et elle est une femme que
faire quand même temps je pense que les
gens ils mettent beaucoup de projets là
tu dans le camp même dans ce sens au
niveau du casting sexuelle c'est y en a
qui disent que si la chirurgie profite
ainsi pas vraiment les femmes merlin de
transcription jamais l'opération pas
parce qu'on peut les moyens c'est juste
que pour une discipline et ça marche ça
les dérange pas parce que je trouve
c'est sûr que la société les gens sont
beaucoup ignorant par rapport à ça par
rapport à chaque différences de chaque
personne trans tout le monde est
différent comme une femme et un homme
nous les jo tout le monde est différent
mais pour toi une personne trans c'est
quoi ce que ces deux moments tu dis qui
était un homme à qui je suis maintenant
une femme je me suis sans comme une
femme gît je pense avoir toujours une
forme parce que ça parte à ce moment là
que d'être en sous sol où il ya des
étapes à franchir
moi je pensais à ce moment là d'être
acquis même au niveau et hormonothérapie
ça maintenant et en éducation il y en a
qui la feront jamais l'hormonothérapie
mais qu'ils veulent quand même passée
dans la société en tant que femme qui
veut c'est sûr c'est vraiment relative
pour tout le monde que tout le monde va
avoir son opinion là dessus
évidemment mais c'est ça veut rien
identité de genre tu pues même pour le
gouvernement le tpo nécessairement avoir
besoin d'avoir commencé une
hormonothérapie pour changer tes papiers
en terme de femmes et de non ti pas que
chez moi pour moi être engeance et quand
tu sais toi même que le genre qui est à
l'extérieur et pas celui que tu as à
l'intérieur
fox et comme rien n'est ce pas
la minute glamour que tu sais que tu es
à l'extérieur n'est pas celui qui assume
en tant que la différence corporelle est
pas la même chose que ton genre
l'intérieur pour moi tu étrangères puis
toi dans ton cas spécifique qu'est ce
que c'est arrivé dans ton parcours
est-ce que c'est depuis tout petit et
non oui si je dis j'ai toujours su qu'il
souhaitait tout faire un des os et comme
dans l'enfance le beh oui non parce que
ses potes est différent des autres qui
ont présenté comme sait pas vraiment ce
qui pour les filles ce qui pour les
goûts oui oui et non si comme tu es
vraiment une statue sais pas où tu es ce
que tu veux ou ce qui est normal qu'ils
pas normal moi je te dirais que mes plus
gros signe un thème dans l'enfance
mais en vieillissant ordonnée et si j'ai
comme mon cerveau est un petit peu black
out tout ce que le rentier adulte quand
ici ce que tu fais dans la vie quand on
sait qu'il devra être définie dans ta
tête s'ils ont un peu cliché
charlesbourg a dit que pour moi il y en
a c'est plus une question moi c'est
comme dans la vingtaine début début
vingtaine puis c'est là que j ai pas
fait le choix de le faire mais que j'ai
décidé d'assumer vraiment mon sentiment
intérieur de deux paniers d'afr dans ce
cheminement
c'est c'est tellement
eux une étape
normes on dirait une marche c'est parce
que souvent les mettons moi je veux je
veux changer certains certains aspects
de ma personne qui savent être des
petites étapes qui sont pas aussi énorme
que de juste faire le show de se dire ok
aujourd'hui je commence ma transition
mais ça c'est peut-être un moment
probablement qu'on peut pas comprendre
comment on se sent en occitan que ça ne
vais pas arriver j'aime impressionnant
si c'est fait c'est quand même quelque
chose de très simple c'est sûr c'est une
grosse décision au sujet des décisions
chaque tome on doit dire ce n'est pas un
choix c'est pas un choix mais tu fais tu
prends la décision de le faire pour
qu'ils feront jamais canaux comme
caitlin génin qu'ils font à 60 et puis
pour moi c'est ce qui me donnait comme
mon coup de pied pour me dire je veux
pas attendre d'avoir 60 ans pour faire
ce qu'ils avaient perdu tout ce temps le
tout ce temps là pour profiter de qui
suit vraiment y accéderaient c'est très
stressant parce que il ya plein de
choses en date a été pour moi si ça
paraît superficiel mais le physique pour
moi toujours été important qui est
passée la société toujours été important
j'étais comme je lé fais tu le fais tu
ici page et eu les moyens de le faire
parce que pour moi j'avais besoin
d'avoir des moyens pour le faire et
comme j'ai tous les moyens légaux
c'est comme vous avez mais c'est
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de réflexions
que c'est des années de réflexion c'est
trop gentil choisissant une semaine ces
gens ça prend du temps le pour t'assurer
que c'est vraiment ce que tu veux
puisqu'il faut que tu consultes tout
pour être sûr que c'est surtout la
caisse quand même est-ce quelque chose
oui c'est une grosse entreprise ont
embarqué là-dedans et est ce que tu as
eue pendant toute cette tension là des
moments de doute des moments où ce qui
te disais est ce que je suis en train de
faire la bonne affaire pour moi j'ai pas
eu de moments de doute
en fait moi comment jolie fille est
requis
chez que ça pue vaut peut-être paraître
bizarre pour quelques gens mais moi
j'avais commencé ma transition avant de
m'afficher physiquement d'avoir fait ma
communion des tours à peu près six mois
c'est pour commencer l'hormonothérapie
puis être sûr qu'en commençant tout ce
que je me sentais bien dans cette
optique et mentalement les changements
étaient positifs et négatifs parce que
si jamais tu en sais pas vraiment ce qui
était le problème
bah c'est sûr avec l'hormonothérapie
mentalement tout change publicité
changement pour toi dans ta tête puisque
logiquement si négative
c'est mauvais signe je voulais être sûr
de passer avant même de le dire à tout
le monde j'ai comme attendu trou au
moins avant de tirer mes parents avant
le drame la meilleure amie j'ai vraiment
attendu longtemps avant de dire aux gens
juste pour être sûr avec moi même côté
son le fait vraiment tout seul je les
fais vraiment petit mais c'était
important pour moitié pour commencer à
dire à tout le monde y est je dégaine
finalement dans deux mois je commence la
maintenance et puis on a là des fois que
et comment une transition plus
finalement que des transitions parce
qu'ils se rendent compte que c'est pas
ça mais je voulais vraiment pas faire ça
arrive souvent débile
qu'est ce que ça fait se situe dit que
des changements dans ta tête
c'est là tu te rends compte chez c'est
ce que tu veux vraiment qu'est ce que ça
fait
concrètement comme changement
si vraiment un changement tire et tue
quelque chose que tu peux dire que le
soleil a vraiment eu un changement
précis à ce niveau là mais que
logiquement ben je te dirai
psychologiquement sa réparation mais je
te dirai vraiment dans l'attitude enlève
vision de voir la vie j'ai jamais une
vision des pressings la vie jamais
jamais jamais mais je voyais vraiment
les choses d'un meilleur hang l'amour
d'une autre façon je voyais mon corps
d'une autre façon puisque le corps
changer aussi fait que le repos avec des
changements physiques ma psychologie
si ça change c'est pas que je te dirais
que c'était surtout la vision la vision
de ma vie je me sentais que je devais le
bon patin je me rendais ce que je
voulais c'est vraiment le mot thérapie
dans le fond le sa coupe la testostérone
s'adonne restreint c'est ce qui fait que
ce sommet c'est fou de penser que si
clairement penser qu'il y aurait des
changements physiques mais même dans ta
manière de réfléchir sans qu'un
changement le cerveau mais c'est parce
que les hormones sont tellement
importants dont vous bossez sûr c'est
vraiment tout un changement chimique le
quelqu'un qui est au smic hormonal petit
puis par plein plein de choses qui sont
reliés avec les hormones pis j'ai
vraiment j'ai vraiment vu le clown aux
thérapies a changé complètement ma tête
semaine du côté amos sexuelle c'est
vraiment différent ma vision de tout ça
le change et la testostérone ouais c'est
vrai que c'est un feeling différent une
femme souvent sa main feeling sexuelle
différence à la une façon d'aimer
différemment peut-être pas pour tout le
monde mais comme général ma parole que
ça vient vraiment changé ce qui s'est un
peu anti féministe est en train de 10
dans un sens qu'il ya un cerveau deux
hommes forts
c'est exactement c'est parce qu'on peut
on peut avoir des discussions mettant
toutes les discussions qui ont peu à
voir avec un homme pour une femme qui
parle ensemble de comment il voit la
sexualité comme un voile amour tu peux
pas vraiment le comprendre ce que
l'autre te dis parce que tu sais toi tu
veux pas vécu mais mais mais toi tu as
vu les deux côtés oui mais ça c'est fou
parce que tu peux réaliser à quel point
ben à quel point ces différents faits
n'est vraiment sûr c'est vraiment même
intéressant pour ses pas pu voir la
différence des tul un vrai
justement une personne spéciale mais
qu'est ce que c'est non mais en tout cas
moi ça me fascine pauvresse je trouve ça
extrêmement intéressant d'un point de
vue psychologique de savoir que
[Musique]
qu une réaction chimique peut changer il
peut changer quelque chose dans une
personne dernièrement qu'une je parle de
mes amis qui travaille à l'université
mcgill qui fait le lien entre les les
athlètes et les universités dans le
fonds pour les athlètes universitaires
puis ils viennent de passer une règle
pour les athlètes 30
parce que ça c'est quand même taux de
chips et mettons un homme qui devient
une femme ou un homme qui est une femme
qui est ce qu'il tombe et yonne avec les
femmes où est-ce qu'ils confectionnent
un client parce que tu es tout dépendant
de de ton niveau de changement c'est
exactement dépendantes au niveau de
changement hormonal du béton et tu peux
être une femme et avec un taux de
testostérone beaucoup plus haut qui va
faire que tu veux combien quand les
femmes puis tu veux juste être dans le
fond un homme qui confectionne avec des
femmes outil un corps d'homme
qu'ambitionne condé femmes
mais finalement la règle qui ont pas
cessé tu dois avoir le taux d'hormones
qui est selon je pense le gouverneur
canada qui classe dans un des deux
jeunes passent des fois il ya des femmes
qui peuvent avoir un taux si une femme
naturelle comme beaucoup plus haut que
ça existait une souris aux olympiques
connie deux médailles d'or aux
olympiques au 1 800 mètres mais c'est
son nom malheureusement ce n'est celle
africaine ce week-end puis lt alors
vraiment une chef d'hommes une voix
d'homme pitt est allé naturellement
nouveau testostérone ultra élevée qui
fait quand même fallu carte sd phase de
tests de féminité pour pour
compétitionner crowley qui la classe
vraiment dans finalement avec une femme
parce que je pense quand même qu'il
fallait qu'elle trouve des moyens de
réduire son niveau testostérone pour en
être éligible mais ces deux or c'est
bizarre c'est que vous trouvez moi je
trouve ça moi je trouve sa voie par la
jeci ma blonde salle intéresse beaucoup
le dit la communauté lgbt qc ca
la partie s'est personnellement puis on
en avait parlé de ce sujet là dessus je
demande mon ami de l'unique
en à cerner comment comment approcher
cette question parce que personne qui
voudrait que les femmes les hommes
compétition ensemble je dois ce serait
juste une faible c'est plate de le dire
mais c'est au niveau sportif au niveau
biologique ses pilotes je remettais à ça
remet pas du tout en doute le droit de
se définir soi même puis de choisir qui
qu'on veut un nom exact selon pas non
plus demander à ces gens là ne pas faire
de sa liberté personnelle qu'est ce
qu'on faisait avec les gens qui rentrent
pas dans les codes binaires trop
difficile puis c'est super sensible
comme étant le qu'elle est la femme
alain taux de testostérone trop haut sur
le côté des garçons c'est ce qui est
c'est ce qu'ils disaient rien comme des
statistiques assez clair c'est un niveau
un peu pas dire de taux de change même
pas comme c'est quoi le vocabulaire mais
oui puis les ans alors dérange l'époque
sans savoir que sa méthode qui voyait
l'équipe avec une femme mais comment ça
vient c'est quoi la définition de la
femme puis de l'homme d'enfants pour
tous en même temps parce que le dit
clairement si la femme a tout l'air d'un
homme a le chef d'un homme à la voix
d'un homme le tout d'un homme mais
mettons à brive agen c'est comme une
femme 10 mai
un métissage foster comme une femme si
je dis pas c'est être en chambre puis
est un cheminement pour devenir un homme
moi je la mettrais du côté des zoos
parce que personnellement s'identifie
comme un homme aux compris alors écoute
je suis quand même encore sur moi
j'avais pas et je n'avais pas de bonnes
avait juste pas de réponse parce que je
me disais c'est 6 h
je me disais rien alain fauchard et je
suis une autre exemple dans le monde du
mmo une autre athlète que je me suis mis
son nom mais c'est une femme trans qui
est arrivé dans le temps long du combat
quant aux lions et les mixtes art
martial en ayant déjà fait sa transition
il a complété les comptes des femmes ici
à
[Musique]
démolissez le teaser à tabac c'est parce
qu'elle avait une force d'hommes le tai
chi
on parle même plus de sport télé c'est
la sécurité des personnes qui sont une
femme et c'est ce qu'avec leur
monothérapie ça change je pense que ça
dans la règle qui disait c'est qu'ils
ont
tu peux c'était un itunes et hommes et
et une femme puis que tu fais la
transition
tu peut compétitionner contre les femmes
si justement avec la thérapie tutut à
travers l'autre côté de ça les claviers
306 ok c'est ce qu'ils faisaient là je
me dis côté technique c'est un milieu
qui approchent ou d'avoir d'objectivité
que ailleurs il ya un homme au moyen de
pape sy ben correct c'est un peu ça le
débat aussi des fois je sais c'est
biologie versus ce qui construit par la
société le titre peu
peut-être bien logiquement n'est un
homme est identifié au construit social
qui la femme plus où je sais ce que je
faisais
[Musique]
c'est ce 2 2
de refuser d'être ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle représente 6 jusqu'à tant que
tremplin la société je chante les genres
je pense que tu peux décider de ne pas
ce que tu veux dans la vie j'ai mangé
potes n'ont aucun problème avec cela
mais je ne demande aucun problème
d'autant que les gens soient heureux
avec leur choix puis que les gens soient
bien c'est ce qu'il est il important
regardez en regardant des vidéos et moi
je suis tombé sur ceux de tulle et les
commentaires de eight g10 j'ai tout le
temps tellement de la musarde c'est en
sortant un certain d'occupation 2 je
suis j'ai été exposé à des commentaires
de diriger un film tellement la misère à
comprendre que quelqu'un prenne la peine
d'écrire du raid sur ces jeux doit-on
canaux spécifiques comment tu te
ramasses pour aller dire c'est qu'on
intéresse c'est clairement une menace de
mort tu dois pourtant recevoir les types
inouïe comme ask achète une vie des
phases d afrique d'hitler comme tu
devrais brûlé
voilà j'ai vu c'est l'antéchrist c'est
pas un peu trop ambitieux et comment
quand tu gères avec ça parce que j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup plus de
positif
comme tu dis avoir beaucoup beaucoup
plus mais mois d'expérience en fait le
le négatif sur les sens positif c'est
lui c'est lui qui se voit moi non pas
par sa sève rien un peu si ridicule des
fois ça se peut pas ça m'affecter puis
en et demain le trois quarts de mes
commentaires des c'est tout du ridicule
c'est sûr il y en a qui vient de toucher
des touches un peu plus sensibles gens
ma voix ou jean mon orientation sexuelle
parce que j'étais un coût certes avec
1go quinzaine ging je ne comprends pas
où tu trouves une idylle
non mais comme il ya je ne sais pas si
vous avez vu mystery mais je suis je
laisse un commentaire si j'ai fait une
vidéo de break à un dramatique
j'avais fait en vue de régler ses
touches froide bientôt le box puis géant
900 commentaires mais est ce que vous
vous considérez gay
c'est comme si un vagin donc non trois
petits points
quelqu'un qui a commenté non mais tu
crois vraiment pas que tu es un vrai
d'agen
est ce que je comprends pas par ses
services alors par rapport à transphobie
puis ajuste l'ignorance un espèce de
concepts des jarrets l'élite méthode les
gens qui sont non binaire dans une
grosse cage le tient à et rend ça veut
dire que shimell non je sais pas ce que
c'est par le ccdh et je pense que sa
porte de garage
c'est à dire ceux c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui sait vient simplement
tient nettement 1 qu'est ce que chaque
personne au entre les jambes ça
appartient chacun connaisse encore non
ça change absolument rien je suis
beaucoup les gens apportent autant
d'importance à sion c'est pas un sujet
que tu abordes avec quelqu'un d'autre
chose que tu dis à péage entre temps
condor était ébéniste beauzac est une
question personnelle c'est qu'il a
effectué ces commentaires lors il colle
un peu sur le dos vraiment c'est sûr il
y en a six qui viennent de casser c'est
comme j'ai dit tantôt ma foi plutôt bien
non c'est vraiment ridicule quand on en
est j'ai comme un 90% de positif ou
négatif
ça va me toucher plus que ça c'est tout
en son honneur puis ça a dû tellement
rendre ce grand tout là mais j'ai de
l'expérience
tellement plus beau c'est vrai mais tes
proches eux dans tout ça est ce que est
ce qu'ils t'ont appuyé à 100% ce que
tout le monde a été vraiment à 100% a
mis toutes mes associés négatif sur la
chanceuse mais je suis vraiment chanceux
parce que tout le monde se porter à 300
%
il faut dire que j'ai toujours été aussi
naze une famille qu'elle acceptait tout
j'ai toujours été une personne folle et
extravertie tgt maquilleur dans le temps
je me maquille un petit taquet j'ai
jamais été dans un milieu comme
comment les conservateurs c'est ce jeudi
pour ghost recon
ah bon coming back et oui ça c'est cool
est ce que tu penses qu'il ya des gens
en fait la réponse c'est sûrement oui
mais combien tu penses que de personnes
qui vivent dans le mauvais score mais
que parce que dans un milieu restrictif
ferons jamais de changement ce que tu
pense qu'il y en a beaucoup
moi je pense qu'on est beaucoup plus
qu'on pense ouais vraiment je pense que
demain c'est une statistique les
remettons homosexuels c'est gentil mais
j'ai 15 ans a besoin que ses camps mais
ces foules à quel point il y en a
beaucoup c'est moins étonnant que les
gens cherchent soit des messages se soit
plaint d'affaires est tout le temps là
il y en a beaucoup le genre dx que j'ai
eues dans le passé il a une qui depuis
que le ils font une transition qui
comprend à quel point le monde est petit
mais à quel point ces six proches
legendre chaque personne mais souvent
les personnes vont jamais se réaliser
vont jamais vraiment accomplir ça et
puis le faire pour de vrai ou jamais
comprendre c'est quoi la dépression
pourquoi ce qui est au delà des primes
comme ceux au pourquoi il ya quelque
chose qui fonctionne pas dans leur vie
sexuelle
des fois ça vient de pauline truc là
parce que je lisais que quand même un
auto des gens trans qui souffrent de
dépression je pense que oui il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup c'est extrêmement
difficile c'est certain 6h puis souvent
ils savent pas c'est quoi le leur propre
support et des sexes pour ceux qui sont
en dépression puis en bout d'un an
drogue qui vont à l'armée pour essayer
de changer leurs pensées bien le
beaucoup de personnes dans la ville
ces foules sans fil je peux si vous avez
déjà tout moi non plus pour des amis
dans l'armée mais je non je ne sais pas
certainement qu'ils aient des irakiens
des gens dès qu'ils vont pas ce que je
vais mettre dans un carrosse bissau
cette question de suivre le malade
molsheim ouais j'ai j'avais quelque
chose que je voulais demander
l'arrivée par addition ya narcisse est
un artiste que je suis sur ben que j'ai
découvert en fait je vous connaissez les
tiny des sponsors sur youtube c'est dans
les bureaux de pilleurs qui comme la
radio de radio canada aux états unis qui
avaient des artistes à faire des shows
ainsi l acoustique dans leur studio puis
c'est vraiment un petit bureau y délivre
en arrière pis si c'est pas cool c'est
le gros gros artistes qui vont le cas
chaque année un concours dans votre
vidéo de ta musique puis j'ai acheté un
petit volet offert un spectacle puis la
personne qui était choisie aujourd'hui
s'appelle naya il joue aujourd'hui cette
année naya izumi puis
mais il joue la getz pays chantepie
ils ont posé les vidéos de lui qui fait
face à thoune tingaud piller lardin
gotti qui chacun c'est bon tu vas voir
ses anciennes vidéos qui y tu as bien
fait c'est pis ils cheveux longs
italiens à fait pu lui jeta main
je lisais son parcours ville pendant
sept ans à vis densifier comme en tant
que fille
il est revenu qui était bon qu'il va
retourner puis comme l'eau ce moment ils
s'identifient en tango mais pendant sept
ans à vis et ancien temps que fiable je
pense pas que je pense pas que qui ont
permis aucune transition je pense et moi
c'est juste que c'est un gars maintenant
ok mais pendant sept ans ali était une
femme à qui le yi tang au hockey ouais
mais ça ne sent pas parce que je pensais
qu'il ne pensait qu'une fois que tu
rationnés mais probable pendant sept ans
j'ai peut-être profiteurs monothérapie
sinon je pense pas c'est quand même
quelque chose je pense que u2 de
transition physique
ouais ouais ouais ok mais c'est fou à
quel point tu avais tu trouves et avait
su retrouver mais on va finir ce sujet
fait pour ta question
mais moi car je vais sites opérés kajima
vaginoplastie en été comme cette fille
je pense
pi 2 go quelques uns des gosses les
affaires un pénis mais logos faisait
faire un vagin
mais on le savait si je savais pas si je
peux demander à chaque personnage que tu
fais un régime végétarien bénisse puis
comme on n'osait pas demandez pas ce que
je te dis dans salles d'attentes même
temps non c'est parce que on rester là
pendant genre sept joueurs qui va qu'on
dormait ensemble l'important maintenant
c'est tout simple on vivait tous
ensemble pas qu'on crée des liens tout
de 10 ans puis c'est comme j'y parlais
au g et tish je savais pas si j'osais
peuvent poser des questions mais je ne
savais pas peut-être que c'était une
fille comme avec un hoax nine film qui
avait vraiment encore la dengue au
quotidien j'osais pas trop rentrer dans
les détails mais finalement on s'est
acheté sur facebook on s'est reparlé pis
c'est vraiment un gars il me dit qu'il
est non binaire
mais qui sait faire la machine parce
qu'il se sentait mieux avec l'idée
d'avoir un vagin
qu'est ce t'en ai comme un gout avec ses
puces a été approuvée le gouvernementale
parce que ces pays il appartient la
charge si vous saviez pas là j'ai la
vérité vidéo s'est fait tout seul a été
approuvée gouvernemental puisque
logiquement sexuelle depuis toute
facture mais qd on est vraiment en
tenant un grand cercle depuis c'est un
homme est capital en guinée pile il
s'était fait ravage un témoin pas trop
de questions je vois comment ça se passe
les lumières sont fermés mais il sentait
mieux avec l'idée d'avoir un accès
direct est énorme plus ça va être
acceptée plus haut du monde qui vont
décider d'être les personnes qui sont
réellement passés juste posé tellement
oui
puisque je le dit alors c'est ma blonde
est en panne sexuelle
il ya beaucoup de gens mais ton moyens
aucune mes amis de gars qui vont venir
me voir pour me parler d'expérience
homosexuels qui on utilise même s'il ya
plus de gays bisexuels qu'on pense
mais ça reste quand même un tabou parce
que moi je dégage pas probablement
l'oreille de quelqu'un qui veut bien
recevoir battu en 1 clic qui va qu'il
faut comprendre c'est mais même à bron
étonné que l j'imagine que les gens
l'associent plus à la diversité sexuelle
et à tous ceux mais il ya beaucoup de
monde qui vont l'avoir beaucoup de gars
qui vont en avoir pour des gars terreau
sexuel qui lui racontent leurs
expériences homosexuelles
parce qu'elle j'imagine qu'à la tire ce
est ce que toi tu es des jeunes qui
viennent de parler eux spécifiquement à
toi passe pour s'ouvrir sur des défis
line qui ont emmené dans deux sont trop
sûr de comprendre vraiment plus ou moins
sur l'orientation sexuelle
c'est vraiment par rapport au chanteur
mais plus un message les brumes à l'eau
si je rends compte pas assez de gens
puis de ces chèques pas assez proche des
gens tu sais pour qui vient d'en parler
comme seul je sais pas comment j'ai
saisi le message
mais sa joie c'est sûr il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup qu'ils m'expliquent
qu'ils savent pas expliquer sa politique
et ses copains cette question ils savent
pas si c'est son truc qui ont besoin il
pose des questions pour valider est ce
que c'est ça suppose au messie note ici
quand même à moi mais prend le temps de
répondre en détail à ces personnes des
conseillers j'ai peur j'ai pas patché
paul tamasy j'ai pas non plus la 100%
compréhensible c'est moi j'ai vécu ce à
26 pour n'importe qui c'est différent le
tipi j'aime mieux pour dire des choses
qui peuvent
viré mais mal reçus ou peut-être que
c'est pas comme ça que j'aime mieux
référer à un sexologue un psychologue ou
dire qu'il faut qu'il parle est une
bonne personne pour ça c'est sûr de mes
conseils ci ont besoin de conseils mais
cgg mieux pas trop donné l'impression
que je suis une psychologue tout la même
j'en apprends aujourd'hui puis toi c'est
en voyant un psychologue sexologue que
sept minutes mais nous y était c'est sûr
que pour faire ce cheminement le topo
choix d'un psychologue un peu chaude ou
un sexologue pendant beaucoup de temps
pour parce qu'il faut que tu ailles
l'approbation de quelqu'un tu peux pas
commencer sur comme ce schéma parlant de
chuter si je veux devenir une fille
demain je vais très bien fait de même
aux îles mais pour cheminement amener du
calme apparent topo choix devant un
psychologue puisqu'un sexuelle a pas que
moi je sais pas ce que c'est juste à
l'est puis comme ça m'a vraiment
confirmer mais je savais déjà en allant
là qu'est ce que j'y allais pour ce jeu
stage était déjà ma vie pour ça mais je
savais que c'était par le fallait je
pars au sein du oui pour nous lancer
mais en même temps c'est important parce
que ça peut être tellement d'autres
choses plus ma psychologue et sexologue
mais tout expliquer que j'en ai défaut
qui venait qui croyait extérieur
finalement c'est d'autres choses il ya
plein de choses qui peuvent ne pas
interférer la dame fait que je pensais
vraiment important dans les paroles
quelqu'un qui s'y connaît
est-ce que ça fait longtemps que c'est
reconnu par le gouvernement pour les
chirurgies son sens il taille de la dame
nature mais bon niveau mais il ya eu
juste au niveau de la vaginoplastie
halle pour les chirurgies et puis je
pense que c'est depuis 2006 si je me
trompe pas si je me trompe pas mais ça
c'est 2006 que c'est vraiment été que le
gouvernement paie pour cela que le
système pour ça et avant ce nom
évidemment beaucoup de gens ont payé
pour leurs opérations dans passé piste
est plus cher ça valait plus cher
qu'aujourd'hui même parce que maintenant
question c'est un peu plus facile
mais depuis 2006 à peu près égales pour
ce puits se tait l'hormonothérapie avec
les jeux de la bonne nouvelle que le
gouvernement reconnaisse
vraiment si seulement parce que c'est
certain que c'est pas tous les défis
tous les pays que c'est celle que tu es
chanceux d'être et au québec quelque
chose que j'aime beaucoup
à propos de toi c'est débat promet
d'être une personne extrêmement
flamboyante qui danse et vidéo ça
transparaît puis j'ai un plaisir fou à
ajuster regarder complètement eux désolé
pour l'expression mais crise et par la
tête et par là même des mythes des
censure des posts censure et n'ont
aucunement maintenant je regarde ta
vidéo sur ta routine natation la routine
le diatta c'est un sujet tellement je
devais j'ai jamais entendu parler de
tout jamais dit ça fait deux ans que ça
existe
petit j'ai jamais entendu parler de ça
est ce que toi et activement tu veux
expliquer les choses telles qu'elles
sont et brisé un peu les murs puis le
silence les non dits sur toutes les
affiches tout avis en fait baver tout à
fait moi je trouve que c'est vraiment
important que les insectes qu'ils
sachent tout sens des petits flafla ou 5
tout à l'heure aux non plus parce que
moi je pense que c'est pas important
puisque ces potins non plus inapproprié
c'est tellement surprenant c'est trop
éducatif qui est des choses sans dire
c'est quoi mettre des choses que tu es
pas encore prête à discuter ou quête du
n'est pas encore les lots bas vraiment
bas
maintenant ce que je peux j'ai toujours
pensé au bien et au chômage j'ai parlé
avec les gens mais on refasse vidéo ou
encore par nos instruments qui a montré
pendant qu'à mais ses minous pour être
démonétisé autre chose ça prend vraiment
maintenant c'était souvent
ouais parce que c'est ici même j'avais
fêté ma vidéo de sas qui m'ont racing
marc sexuelle la deuxième partie elle a
déjà été supprimés un contenu
inapproprié
comme c'était la vidéo la plus
d'éducative la plus importante armée
quartier
c'est comme si moi ça m'a vraiment
affecté
c'était tellement important puisque
après l'époque à masquer un ordinateur
pouvait venir jugé que ce n'était pas un
bon coup sur la tête sadjadpour vous
avez comparé commencer je laisse on est
comme tendre comme des pacistes informé
il ya déjà une vidéo comme ce qui existe
des tubes à la pelle du jeu et vous avec
un google s'appelle davy oui je pense
puis à lui monte sur l'âge et puis comme
c'est lui et gif qui je pense que
peuvent vraiment beaucoup vu du vagin
avec l'ailier comme surprise mais moi je
me sens encore plus drôle parce ce qu'on
voit maintenant c'est du jeu soient les
actions achetées puis juste à réaction
fait dans le fossé la personne sur
laquelle besson manqué je remette un
trépied comme la cimade une différence
c'est clairement moi c est créée par un
passing personnes elle c'est naturel
c'est sûr que des tyrans spi la
curiosité de haut mais moi j'ai jamais
vue du vagin en réalité sur internet ou
weeds
mais en réalité il vraiment intéressant
quand même je trouve de discuter des
différents examens
c'est un peu normal ou si chaque mais
probablement je pense que oui en terme
c'est physiologique ne sais pas comment
des sushis rendu scientifiquement mais
comme si au niveau des élèves tout c'est
sûr qu'une différence
on peut parler de solliciter comme les
petites lèvres
selon moi qui font la différence qu'ils
sont différents s'il y en a mais si je
te dis jamais ce que j'ai vu sur
internet cet être humain pour les jets
logeant le métier il y en a des volcans
dit lève un peu plus le dos ou un peu
plus long de votre année un peu plus
mais moi c'est pas du tout comme ceux
affectés je ne sais pas si c'est normal
s'il y en a qui ont en tout cas déjà
devant
mais ici c'est oui c'est différent mais
peut-on probablement je sais pas encore
mais très peu le cadre après l'opération
mais dans le lendemain
est ce que tu te réveilles tu sais ap il
est enfin j'ai dans mon corps pieds il
ya un énorme changement aussi commencé
notre journée puis c'est jugé en
revanche aujourd'hui puisque je sais ce
que tu te sens complètement différent
aussi la continuité mais je te dirai
c'est la continuté un peu parce que tu
ne veux pas travailler le lendemain je
peux pas rien voir c'est comme coop qui
a réalisé réalise un peu plus que quand
que tu t il toutes les vannes à son hôte
et peeters
mais c'est vraiment qui nous fait une
forêt un peu dans ce sens où c'est
excitant de dire que cette partie look
toujours d'une dysphorie est parti mais
sûrement élections comme malgré ce que
vous êtes sûr que vous me l'avez haute
et plus jean guyon voulions au tessin
moi je déconne je sais je sais comme
l'hôte et le cheveu en bataille j'ai
passé des assurés
à table d'opération que non moi c'était
juste comme une continuité puis comme
justin pas une étape de plus de fait
mais juste comme une finalisation genre
c'est la dernière étape du challenge me
dis moi mettons les dépenses et je me
sers
perry pearn à peine si j'ai une marâtre
larnack on dit toi mettons le ca doit
etre douleur jours après le non je te
jure
six jours après on faisait déjà de
dilatation qui ont rentré des gros
affaires vous avez vu le truc au bingo
jours après c'était déjà dedans cliquez
pas que c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
foulent facile puis mes mains c'est ce
que moi je suis quelqu'un qui prend la
douleur vraiment facilement ok c'est
juste pas la meilleure référence pour
parler de tout mais je les ai toujours
trouvé ça vraiment facile
c'est ce qui était plus difficile c'est
d'avoir petit j'avais des tuyaux le qui
sortait de moitié vingt quatre étages
viendrez vous restez plus l'idée que je
les jetais restreint pas pouvoir faire
grand chose pour important marché je
peux pas faire puisque je voulais
vraiment faire exprès ce qui était comme
négative pour moi plus que la douleur
depuis des antidouleurs et en donnant à
main puis avant d'être ici vraiment
stressé avant l'opération ben je t'ai
pas mal de chinois - je te colle
vraiment à fait avec ce que j'avais hâte
que ce soit fini
plusieurs heures quand même pas si
l'occident que ces deux heures c'est
vraiment pas long le post genre
d'opération la deux en aurait tendance à
penser que c'est sa preuve
mais admettons pour un gars une fille
qui devient angoisse et une neuf heures
et où c'est plus complexe cette région
gréement copley c'est quoi la différence
la transition est moins que important
complexe c'est plus l'opération qui est
complexe nous bousculait si leur
transition jpac est plus facile mais
une fille que d'un gosse et les poils
repoussent la voix change c'est tout
change chaque c'est vraiment difficile
pour une fille qui devient co que dans
la société on remarque c'est une fille
avant je pense pas qu'il y ait pour 1 go
qui deviennent feed c'est nous les eaux
change pas limite change un peu mais pas
autant que la phase change pauthe il
faut que tu fasses beaucoup plus de
procédures pour changer quelque chose
qu'une fille qui danse et je pense que
leur transfert est plus facile en tant
que tel mais est un peu plus mon champ
apparaît moyens
ça paraît moins une fois du
transitionner ces sottises
je suis plus calmes et lyon dans sa
série est mal vraiment nettement
vraiment mais au niveau de la chirurgie
c'est vraiment celle ci font comme un go
par semaine tandis qu'ils font peut-être
qu'ainsi fipac semaine c'est vraiment
difficile comme opérations qui sont deux
médecins sur la paix sur le patient donc
pendant neuf heures c'est long un fort
bruit si l'on est ce que est ce que
c'est un pourcentage 50/50 degauque défi
ou de filles deviennent des gueules
est-ce que c'est 50 50 mais je pense que
vous vouliez moi je sais pas honnêtement
je ne sais pas ce genre de statistiques
leur toit qu'est ce que tu penses moi je
pense que ben je dis super jeu peut-être
que je me trompe complètement mais je
pense qu'il ya plus de gars qui
deviennent des femmes
mais je pense qu'on s'en rend pas compte
c'est cela qui dans le temps tôt c'est
peut-être que on les remarque juste pas
c'est ce que je sais moi je pense parce
que comme je disais c'est vraiment plus
facile physiquement pour effet de
devenir un gars une fille t'imagines le
coq qui revient de l'aqmi et muscler la
grosse barbe la grosse voix clôture une
transition le sport en prenant des
pilules que ça change toi un tel éclat
une question qui est probablement
vraiment nous c'est insultant timidité
des caves inclus
mais mettons le pénis le que qu'elle a
que l'homme trans dans le fossé opposé
louis hiss et sud-sud pénis c'est un
vrai pénis est fait on coiffe ses ils
prennent des études du bruit ok c'est
vraiment pas naturel
honnêtement c'est sur ce stand des
avantages par contre c'est que moins
aisément sa part est plus naturelle
quelqu'un pourrait pas dire mettons
ouais t'es une fille qui faisait encore
l'opération pour créer un pénis c'est
pas nécessairement naturellement sens où
ça ressemble europe ont vraiment oui
mais non impunité sarah jamais l'aspect
complet pis c'est une pompe qui
actionnait manu bel hommage en fac sera
jamais notre île une excitation nature
et l'excitation oui mais pour le paquet
obligations si ce plafond ils prennent
ce genre d'étude brûlé c'est vraiment
quelque chose de trop le jeu peut être
montré une photo sous vide en taule ja
et prennent le dessus du groupe comment
un pommeau jean l'at-il comme quand tu
es plus cher pour faire comme un penny
est ce qu'ils prennent un but de ta
jambe puis prennent lecteurs risquent
gros soucis avec les hormones parce que
une fille qui vient coller clitoris
grossi allonge qu'il a qui prennent ça
pour faire comme les clans peu pour les
sensations
puis mais moins malheureusement c'est ce
qui est moins naturel dans tout ça ok
mais au moins peuvent avoir des
relations sexuelles
un peu plus normale hétérosexuels et sur
un terreau sexuelle on dit ce qui ce qui
est vraiment impressionnant c'est que
tout est sain c'est des vrais seins en
ce moment c'est vrai mais dans trois
jours mais la forme de te convient
professeurs ouais parce que s'embrasser
c'est moins bon en béton mais
fort pour que tes dessins qui pousse
pareil ses notes et ses foules c'est le
moment le plus excitant
les enfants les hormones sacré des
tissus mammaires puis toute activité
vraiment où je suis vraiment une puberté
genre c'est comme si le j'avais mais
quand tu commences à ce constat v12 amp
sur des coustous le tout change
c'est cool oui qui fait que dans trois
jours de procès elles peuvent aussi
aller j'avais
grosse cage thoracique
ce sera possible parce que ces petits
jardins petites boules ça veut dire
mettre en place que depuis que c'est ça
ça va avoir la forme que je coule parce
qu'en ce moment c'est comme c'est ce que
je peux pas considérer que j'ai oui
comme les matins dis-je et dessins d'une
fille qui ont dépéché normal mais à côté
de la musculation mais pas la
musculation et de la façon dont mon tort
c'est fait et c'est sur un peu
différente d'une femme naturelle depuis
limoux ce qui étouffe nice il pousse un
lyon plus un peu plus ses bords que dans
le milieu métiers des filles naturelles
ça pose donc si j'aurais pu vraiment
rester domaine soulève c'est juste pour
moi personnellement mais je pense que
c'est sûr que le fait que j'étais un
homme avance c'est quand même joué avec
la forme et tout le pire c'est que oui
dans ma famille on dessin normal mais
jamais j'aurai atteint la grosseur de st
mais mon alimentation mano pas pour moi
ça peut vraiment liens avec m c'est
vraiment juste comme le physique puis au
niveau de la dette in-game commencer
comment ça s'est passé pour toi
premièrement avant la transition bien
précis pendant puis maintenant notamment
comment ça se passe pour toi est ce que
c'est
[Musique]
est ce que c'est un sujet j'imagine qui
évidemment quelqu'un annonce assez ça
commence quand même que ça s'est passé
pour toi c'est quelque chose que je
pense que ça va intéresser vraiment
beaucoup de monde
ouais mais c'est vraiment une partie
importante et une partie super stressant
c'est sur la prostitution certains puis
tu sais comme moi mettons j'ai jamais
une personne
oui j'ai déjà fréquenté beaucoup
personne ne triche jamais une personne
qui qui faisait n'importe quoi avec
n'importe qui j'étais avant
si tu veux savoir voir notre édition
évidemment j'avais vu des relations
sexuelles homosexuel le jean py deux ans
avant la transition
j'ai je suis personne dans ma vie en
termes de relation de couple et touche
je suis personne
puis quand j'ai commencé ma transition
je me suis promise de jamais de pour
rencontrer quelqu'un non plus surtout
pas durant la transition c'est parce que
feu était vert au début j'étais encore
un gros lot et physiquement par an
surtout j'ai bossé du coming-out ggg
rien changé physiquement vraiment si je
m'étais promis de ne pas tomber en amour
avec personne mais six mois après mais
quand j'ai commencé ma transition mais
le j'ai mon team ex maintenant olivier
que j'ai comme connu mais physiquement
ajoute encore 1 go puis l'hymne avait
connu sur les réseaux sociaux fait que
les réseaux sociaux personne ne savait
ce qui se passait dans ma vie pâques
ça a été important pour moitié lui
parlait chaque jour playmoney il fallait
juste que ça me serve à rien de me
mentir à moi pu demander à quelqu'un
d'autre que s'ils avaient quelque chose
de potentiel alors que peut-être plus
j'avais pris pour acquis ce que la
personne était homosexuel
là j'ai écrit j avais écrit tg dianté il
faut que je te dise comme ça fonctionne
repos je suis en transition tg déjà six
mois de monothérapie j'avais déjà des
saints qui avait poussé
je pouvais pas le cas chez inwi même si
elle évolue juste au kop forfait puis
finalement ç'a donné qu' il était pensé
qu' suel puissance foot et j'ai vraiment
été chanceuse dans un sens au mas dating
game a été quand même facile comme j'ai
tombé sur le jackpot chance au foot et
puis mon homme du moment vraiment suivi
tout le processus exact est encore plus
facile et ça tellement dû aider un
support incroyable dans les villes
d'avoir quelqu'un qui me soutenaient à
chaque épreuve
à chaque moment puis a jamais eu de
moments dans nous comme jamais la
personne que tu t'étais ces deux hommes
une femme ça changerait possession mais
c'était vraiment impressionnant j'ai
géré pas penser que ça a l'airé pu
m'arriver
puis je voulais pas que ça m'arrive mais
finalement je laissais c'est arrivé mais
je voulais pas que ça arrive parce que
je voulais juste pas personne ne voulait
pas que ça arrive aux eaux
avoir quelqu'un qui puisse ne pas qu'ils
puissent me faire recul il si je peux
pas tu peux pas t'en reculé mais c'est
que tu peux rencontrer quelqu'un qui ne
craint ou un type différent
finalement c'est joe peut-être attendre
un peu puis je voulais vraiment pas ce
que je voulais vraiment comme continuer
vers le chemin que je voulais avec moi
c'est important at il une image et
tomber sur quelqu'un qui supportaient
foule se retrouver ma chance ça avec la
vaginoplastie ski à un autre le
maintenant une autre côté stressant que
je retrouve du début de corps jetés
trans le foot il n'y a personne tu dis
tu lis pas l'os comme cgg fait l'amour
une fois sur l'internet avec vous fait
que je suis encore dans le mode de genre
c'est je suis vierge mais pas fier je
suis vierge parlé avec jack pas que je
parlais je sais pas comment ça
fonctionne je fais pas mes limites je
sais pas les sensations étaient là je
redécouvre encore tout le lot de ma
sexualité du passé d'il ya trois mois et
plus loin c'est plus du tout la même
chose
vaka montrer qu'il faut je redécouvre sa
pile là que j'ai pu monter hommes
je me vois mal est tombé sur quelqu'un
puis j'ai commencé au même de côté
sexuel il faudrait vraiment que la
personne soit pour lui ou vert purgeant
comprend 16 puis prendre le temps de
faire ce parce qu'à 25 ans comme hors de
l'ordinaire gens là que moins c'est ce
qui est stressant ce moment pour moi ben
j'imagine j'imagine satisfaisant puis
j'imagine que tu es tu dois malgré tout
pour revenir un peu à ce qu'on parle de
salaire de là quand les jeunes de 12 ans
découvre leur corps je dois découvrir
ton corps - puis comme commencé
tranquillement à savoir qu'est ce que
j'aime - qu'est-ce qui me fait du bien
ce qui me fait pas du bien c'est ce que
j'attends d'un adolescent ce léger
aucune connaissance de ma sexualité
aucune c'est stressant mais ne sait
vraiment qu'on l'a même que de se
toucher soi même quand c'est pas la
sensation je sais pas tu es andré pour
moi c'est pas instinctif vu que j'ai
jamais eu cette partie l'odm n'a pas
compris que même moi expérimentés du
chase comment je n'étais pas la seule
expérience une expérience à date
qu'est-ce qu'elle était positive elle
était positif en terme de sensations
entre de taupo capoter c'est aujourd'hui
ses poteaux cliquer que la première
épisode c6 parlophone man en matière moi
j'écoute et je peut imager pas saigner
j'ai pas été moi je répartis khelcom
gérer ses nuits que j'ai ça reste mal ça
restait plus bizarre comment c'était
possible d'en montrer que je
réfléchissais beaucoup trop à l'idée de
qom
ok là ma limite c'est sur cette fois 60
de ses besoins à cette position laisse à
sa rente port la forêt c'est une
opposition andré qu'elle est tellement
trop je réfléchissais tout ce que j'ai
pas pu
ce thé de sucre tu es ma libido est
l'objet envie de pouvoir profiter de ça
mais je n'ai pas choisi d'expérimenter
des gpo choix de réfléchi mais ça s'est
bien passé je suis vraiment contente
pour ça au moins est ce que c'est
difficile de trouver quelqu'un qui
ouvent à la voir une relation qu une
personne trans ou dans la communauté
lgbt qc c'est normal pcc comme dans la
communauté
mais c'est une bonne question alex tard
je sais pas tant c'est comme je peux sur
les réseaux sait pas à quel point les
gens sont à l'aise avec ça cj port
rencontré personne depuis en fait jules
ledin gvt q mais dans le fond le sait
n'est pas de quel homme hétérosexuel
photo don public
[Rires]
mais ce sujet comme page et je sais pas
je ne sais pas je pense que s'ils vivent
beaucoup de curiosité ouais gens
ressemblent beaucoup de plusieurs
personnes c mais je pense avec beaucoup
de classe et il faut que ce soit fait
avec une personne que j'ai confiance que
c'était bon sens vraiment comme une
fatalité à l'échangé des sentiments mais
d'accord
la personne qui se trouvait sa foule 1.6
et de redécouvrir la sexualité c'est que
ses camarades elle est vraiment c'est
que tu veux être avec quelqu'un avec qui
tu as confiance tu es plus ta sexualité
devient que plus tu la connais plus tu
l'accès plus de toi même tu t'étais des
sexuelle normale - ça devient grave que
ce quinqua confiance 6 points + adiaké
même mois chez qu'est ce que j'aime la
personne c'est qu'est ce qu'elle aime
ensemble les deux ombres un bon moment
c'est fini le make up et c'est ta
première fois au secondaire
post 6 et puis moi j'ai l'impression que
ça va être ma première fois longtemps
quoi donner un sens où tu sais tu vu que
moi c'est que mentalement parlant puis
j'ai parlé avec mon médecin m'a jamais
dit j'ai aucune limite mais mentalement
vu que s'est créée par quelqu'un que
j'ai pas quelque chose que les choses se
détache au clic sur s'est déplacé je
sais pas montré que mentalement parlant
je le vois trop d'un sens scientifique
et non de mon anatomie gens mais se
situe mon métier me dis si vraiment on
anatomy maintenant ça peut pas bouger
comment ce qui se passe ça peut arriver
mais moi mentalement c'est sûr que ça me
fait peur j'en fais que j'ai
l'impression vraiment que je sois avoir
une première fois vraiment longtemps en
termes d'expérimentation 40e de
confiance
ce que j'ai dit loge et souvent ça
s'apprend là le premier tome le première
blonde que le ticket hocine d'habitude
une confiance vidéo on essaie d affaires
plus lent que ça marche parce que si
j'ai eu des expériences uniques après
expérience unique c'est plus dur de cse
c'est quand même important d'avoir le
même partenaire je trouve longtemps pour
moi c'est moi je les fais d'abord avec
mon équipe parce que je sois c'est
vraiment important que ce soit lui parce
que c'est ça faisait deux ans et avait
aucun étudiant aucun stress là on a
commencé confiance parmi elles je peux
avoir l'air d'une chienne et on s'en
fout bien comme je trouvais ça important
c'est sûr évidemment j'aurais voulu
continuer à expérimenter la relation
fonctionne depuis fonctionne plus noté
il faut pas jouer non plus avec les
émotions mais
c'est comme le faut que je trouve
quelqu'un avec qui je je je pouvais
passer un long temps quand même de ma
vie puis expérimenté tout seul puis
avoir confiance en cette personne c'est
comme genre c'est quand même intensité
en relation ça vient un peu dans le même
sens de gens tuent avec quelqu'un que tu
veux c'est une nouvelle expérience
jamais ton de l'anah loua laverty un
couple hétérosexuel
c'est tellement important que joseph
foule confiance à la personne puis que
je reçois foule à l'aide pour un poste
qui arrive y aura jamais de ce que je
reprends importe comme caisse car il n'y
aura jamais de tabous jamais banal que
tu te rends compte que je vois mon
parcours sexuelle de la même façon que
sais je veux pas passer n'importe qui je
veux expérimenté longtemps que la même
personne moi je comprends tout à fait
moi j'avais une autre question aussi
finalement les dix questions qui mêla
dans le fond si je sais que le genre
puis l'orientation sexuelle c'est deux
choses différentes mais tout ce que je
considère maintenant comme
hétérosexuelle ou pan sexuelle ou une
bonne question et c'est sûr je me costa
hétérosexuels en d'expérience là mais
maintenant que je comme complet puisque
j'y suis maintenant que les jambes
on dirait que je serais pas permis
je sais comment que je descendrai comme
ça me dérangerait pas d'expérimenter ou
deux
de d'avoir n'importe quel château
personne dans ma vie j'en fais quand
même mieux pour mettre les bouteilles
which hétérosexuels mais je sais pour
s'est jamais expérimenté le rsa que je
peux pas vraiment dire que c'est
vraiment ce que j'aime c'est vraiment
juste ce que je veux dans ma fiche en
textant sexuelle un peu je ne sais pas
complètement encore c'est ça je ne sais
pas si c'est pour ça ok c'est cool
impies est-ce que tu étais une figure
importante de cette communauté lopy de
surtout d'heure
des gens entrant en général dans ce sens
qu'il était quelqu'un
québec justement un des plus importants
par l'amendé dans ce domaine là parce
que peut-être public qui équipe qui est
quand même l'iran puis 10 octobre où
personne qui te suivent qui est ce que
est ce que ton
l'implication commencer est-ce que c'est
surtout sur internet
est-ce que tu fréquentes en fait tu mets
ton libre et chez paul dukas et langil
âgées ce qui était dans cette communauté
lettre à ces éléments là où tout s'est
vraiment sur internet thewrap notre chez
vous en dit plus sur internet si je
perds foule une personne de communautés
inquiéter oui c'est sûr que je vois dans
le village des fois avec des amis et
j'ai plein d'amis la communauté lgbt
fichu dans la communauté lgbt
c'est inévitable pour moi mais je suis
pas quelqu'un qui si juste avec ce genre
de personne c'est comme j'ai ma petite
vie oui à mes petits amis à repentigny
qui comme je suis vraiment une personne
un peu
chi chi six matchs avec tout le monde
est gentil j'ai pas une copie et
beaucoup de gens des fois que kim se
tenir avec juste des gens de la
communauté lgbt ou juste égayée ou juste
d'être en dessous moi juste comme je me
sens comme tout le monde la famille est
juste tout le monde paie si j'ai des
amis gaming et davies amis étrangers dm
transpire
mais pas bien normal qu'ils n'ont pas de
spécial comme je peux je te dirai c'est
pas mal plus faibles mon affaire si je
peux déjà en remettant c'est comme chez
que j'essayais vraiment beaucoup comme
activé dans ces trucs là moi je suis pas
à ce niveau là mais ton constat pas
activer ce constat vulgarisatrice
peut-être ou juste éducative expérience
mais je fais juste partager ça puis ça
me fait plaisir de partager ces succès
chiche peu pour des causes ou des
fondations spécifique si je peux être
ambassadrices ou un visage ça me ferait
plus entreprenants mais je suis pas la
personne qui veulent militer à l'extrême
pour ce truc je comprends pas ce que ça
vient qu'une certaine pression bien
tenus responsables si je sais pas quel
point ce parcours parce que tu es de jeu
ben est il de transition récemment et
achever ce fut bien parce que par une
période déjà assistons assiette déjà
gérer tout ça parce que dans tout ça on
a tendance à oublier qu'un convoi
quelqu'un mais ton qui s'exposent sur
internet on a tendance à oublier que
cette personne là et elle aussi un
cheminement plus par projet de
cheminement en en deux sexes franches
un cheminement personnel même la
tendance à penser que les personnes
qu'on voit beaucoup en dollars comme
toute figure doubt atteint le niveau 6
comme loin de ceux en études des vies
normales on a tous des objectifs comme
tout le monde
on attendait des trucs dans vie qui font
en sorte qu'on est comme tout le monde
ok c'est vrai dans d'autres sphères
aussi je dirais une victime d'agression
sexuelle ça veut pas dire qui est prête
à aller sur la place finance vous être
un ambassadeur de cette cause le savent
chaque investisseur faire de la façon
qui veulent vivre
bah oui oui c'est clair toi la refonte
fêter tout un travail normal
pitau youtube oui est-ce que comment tu
balances les deux comment tu es ce que
tu mets beaucoup dans ta chaîne youtube
parce que ces décès des vidéos site
danois est quand même très simple c'est
ça reste que ce montage dans la ssi
dynamix effectué - est-ce que tu fais
juste arrivé chez vous 2 tu dis après
une journée travail me tombera ça serait
drôle de faire une vidéo sur ce plot
centraux de préparation par rapport à ça
tu t'assois tout la lumière
j'ai rarement de la préparation on est
mal à moi je suis vraiment plus là
j'aurais personnes qui pillent tuent
c'est très chiant parce que je trouve
que c'est trop préparé c'est comme pas
moins ça manque de personnalité un peu
mais j'ai toujours dit j'ai quand même
un orage petit remettons j'ai tout un
vendredi samedi dimanche lundi et le
vendredi je veux filmer le samedi je
veux monter dimanche doit filmer ou si
j'ai quand même des journées je croyais
pas beaucoup à l'extérieur en tant que
jobs norman pas que ça me permet de
mettre beaucoup de temps dessus machine
mais si j'ai pas juste une chaîne j'ai
des projets autour de ce pas que ceci
ait beaucoup de temps le temps où ceux
qui misent sur les autres projets autre
genre de projet je vais attendre un peu
mais jeudi prochain sacré paquet de
maquillage j'aimerais ça maintenant non
non exemple maquillage mégarde avec ma
blonde
c'est aussi hélas très déçu ce qui est
lu ses collections surveillants ouais ok
que ta job de jours la normale c'est
quoi c'est quand même déjà c'est
vraiment un job à temps partiel je suis
le staff et jean 8ème fois comiques main
je réagis cela parce que j'ai toutes mes
avantages de semaine je peux tout
prendre les congés que joueuse si j'ai
un événement j'ai des projets et jambes
donne tout ce que je veux je veux pas
cacher la tuer puis allez dans quelque
chose de plus sérieux quelque chose du
lundi au vendredi alors que je peux pas
faire du lundi au vendredi jean pas que
moins c'est ce machin ces malades ont
déjà senti quelconque résistance
d'apport de thé employeur ce qu'un coup
dur de transition jamais jamais jamais
jamais 6e les clients du monde de
rénovation des hommes virils qui vont le
changement qui les emploient 10 des
clients fidèles aux essais des clients
que je vois chaque jour je joue à chaque
jour mais si beaux prix mais c'est
vraiment que je vois chaque jour fa qui
ont vraiment tout juste ça mais malgré
ça étrangement il y en a qui cachent
toujours pas
très étrange presque
ouais mais qui sont vraiment plus proche
de - faction comme un look ambigu c'est
anna des fois il ya des trente fois
c'est que cette habitude si c'est pas un
but sous ses hawks aucune dit c'est quoi
ton âge entendu parler de connais rien
là dessus je peux comprendre que
peut-être que ces paumés site mettant de
suivi une fois puis continuer la
mauvaise foi mais c'est sûr que des fois
saviem accrocher les gens des enfants
si c'est la foi qui m'accrochent le plus
la nuit à cause de ma voix
moi ça me trahit beaucoup ok puis des
fois je me force à jobs pourrait
tu es avoir une voix un peu plus de 200
ans mais aussitôt que détient des
enfants de ces super innocence a dit
tout ce que sans ben oui si je parle peu
il dit rien des fois aussi tout que je
parle je suis comme élève puis j'oublie
réfléchi qu'il faut que j'aille voir
sans com
voilà le paradoxe c'est chic c'est mon
parcours que physiquement aussi mal à
l'aise là une belle occasion d'y
expliquer l'ouverture mais des fois je
suis comme je devrais pas parler
d'enfants parce que la voix les hormones
qui changea rien pour ça change harry la
classe toujours que je peux faire c'est
forcé par les urnes je fais ce métier ça
m'arrive le défaut de force de me forcer
gens du métier de mes instincts la
remettons le jeu c'est pas moi je paye
un client qui fait chier le japon va pas
commencer à penser à batman affecte en
vrai que je trouve que c'est trop peu
naturel d'essayer de me forcer comme
juste comme je m'accepte besoin d'y
penser 24 heures sur 24 c'est cela le
spi rio paris c'est ça claque man s'est
même pas je trouve vraiment poste je
trouve pas que ta voix tu ta voix est
grave mais
de là à dire
qu'un enfant fait qu'à mi temps le
voyais en béton le témoin je te vois
plus tu parles puis je me dis pas voyons
c'est pas ce pas la voix de cette
personne me semble t'il des voix
vraiment plus grave que la tienne moi je
me dis pauvre et je me dis je te vois
puis mettons je me place dans un an dans
la peau d'un enfant puis je me dis comme
d'étranges ici le sait une voix grave
mais c'est ça mais non mais un et deux
matches sur les enfants c'est terrible
c'est rendu que ça me stresse de banques
aidées par un qui passe avec des enfants
accueil vraiment puis comme avoir jamais
fait pas partie vraiment de matisse
farid et je me relâche angers puis je
peux bien jouer avec ce n'est seulement
mais de l'eau à ce que ça vienne créer
une anxiété
je trouve ça c'est mon problème
est ce qu'il ya des des recours pour
modification pour f
moi et d'éducation genre mais c'est
vraiment risqué aujourd'hui pas papa
nantes rouen - je trouve que c'est un
peu trop choisi jeu je regardais ma voix
quand même temps c'est ma personnalité
je trouve ça important quand même de
garder ma foi ça me définis comme un
fait en tant que - gabriel marion
quelque chose comme important lagarde et
puis il ya tellement de monde qui dit
ben voyons donc je trouve ça super je
trouve pas ça grave
le clan des voix pire que la science
comme peut-être semeillon tricks et des
personnes des enfants qui voient exit je
sais pas comment ce samedi maintes
reprises hors fortis lease de mode
historique que ça veut dire si fort
hills est temps que ce que tu vois pas
ce que tu feras mieux mais quand il pas
à l'aise avec quelque chose une partie
ton cas où un métier comme un peu comme
une personne à mi-temps avec 6 qui va se
regarder dans le miroir qui va se voir
crosse alors qu'elle n'allait pas nous
disent fort et corporelle jo
ok c'est vraiment quand même dit sorry
c'est quelque chose qui dans ta tête ne
laisserai l'ipo avec la personne que tu
penses que tu es chaud ou six heures
exactes
chaussures ton corps le kiki c'est juste
d'impôts c'est sainté c'est vraiment
juste un espèce de mélange la
psychologie de la façon dont toi tu vois
qui est pas la réalité 2
quand on triche de mélanger ce que tu
vois c'est pas la réalité de ta
mentalité ou vice versa c'est comme il
ya une espèce de mélange réelle
déconnexion en ce que tu vois risque ce
qui était vraiment que je comprends pas
comment peut-on être en jeu disposant
pas que ce que tu vas dans le miroir
c'est vraiment pas le genre que tu es à
l'intérieur c'est dont tu perçois
l'intérieur
est-ce que ça arrive parce que moi je me
rappelle d'une histoire me rappelle plus
exactement qui m'avait raconté ça mais
c'est une fille qui m'avait raconté que
des fois à ce gars en miroir puis on
n'avait pas l'impression de voir la
bonne personne
puis je peux pas expliquer pourquoi
cette personne là et pas de france est
une fée et puis c'est une femme avec pas
l'impression d'être dans le bon corps
jaune comme si c'était une vie en
travaillant je ne sais pas exactement je
sais pas si c'était spirituel et
probablement que si elle l'était
sûrement un très riche il mais à la base
tous et spirituelle c'est comme ça le
fait même si peu tranchant mais 400 pas
dans le bon corse et spirituelle l'idée
de dire que quelqu'un d'autre en jean et
pas dans le bon score
c'est souvent comme les gentilshommes et
une fille car à l'intérieur de moi même
on casse cinq ans dom
c'est une vision très spirituelle parce
que j'ai fait appel à l'embl c'est sur
une dissociation entre justement l'ompi
le corps puisse comme s'ils étaient deux
entités différentes
c'est ce mélange c'est respectueux mais
lui comme je crois va se heurter à une
personne spirituelle
un pack l'imagination de me dire que mon
nom ne fait pas avec mon corps pour moi
c'est pas des potins lydie moi c'était
vraiment moi je suis vraiment plus d'un
sens scientifique ou
mon cerveau m'envoient des messages qui
font en sorte que
mon physique ne fait pas avec les
messages commencé à vraiment voir avec
moi je le vois plus comme aux femmes
c'est ce que tout les signaux sont
féminins mais selon moi c'est vraiment
retient de ce film c'est la caisse comme
ça que tu l'expliquent toi fais le site
parlant mais c'est beaucoup plus facile
de comprendre l'idée de l'angola ou
encore parce que c'est quand je pense à
ceux c'est beaucoup plus facile de mais
moi c'est pas comme si je vois et des
croquis des enfants qui manifesta hull
trop jeune ah oui trois ans quatre ans
oui c'est les premiers signes le moins
il y avait des signes à cet âge
ouais beaucoup même cadre quand la
densité par action s qui ont été surpris
où il avait vu venir
si on est un peu surpris parce que je
pense que c'était habitués avec qui
j'étais devenu très aimé ton les geeks
qui se sont imaginé que les signes de
jeunesse puis quand je leur ai dit un
peu surpris mais après il réfléchit nama
n'était pas vraiment surpris que pitié
commun c'est sûr tu sais ce que tu
apprends c'est tes parents extrême est
mort le plein de choses de temps passe
et les salaires
c'est ce n'était pas tant surpris
est-ce que jeune dessus adhérer ou à
certains stéréotypes féminins déjà joué
des poupées pâture aux femmes oui sauf
que tu fais moi je n'ai pas l'impression
que ça veut vraiment dire quelque chose
pour que des garçons qui sont des gars
sont hétérosexuels plus tard dans leur
vie
quand j'avais des barbies où vous avez
probablement déjà joué avec des projets
comme ceux comme saisisse c'est sûr j'ai
été dans cette catégorie l'homme
pour moi c'était un peu plus poussée
dans les démantèlent pénalité de
d'autres trucs auto puisque deux
véhicules une simulation de coeur la
cause dessous
dans un sens homosexuels parce
qu'évidemment dans le terrain personne
savait qu'à être engeance exister oui un
petit peu un petit peu mais pas beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup une question ce qui
est déjà trop une question est plus
délicate en tout cas plus sujette à
débat qu'est ce que tu penses ce que je
sais que ça suffit que ça existe que des
enfants j'aime bien qu'ils manifestent
soit on leur donne des bloqueurs
d'hormones qui fait que ça retarde la
puberté ou seul annuler complètement ce
qui fait quatre ans si on était plus
facile mais en même temps c'est jeune
pour prendre une décision aussi
importante peut-être qu'est ce que t'as
pas tout le temps moi que tu vois moi
j'aurais aimé ça que ça m'arrive à moi
ok pas que ce soit mon point de vue
beaucoup plus du genre comme je trouve
que c'est une bonne chose c'est sûr que
comme ceux ci c'est super important que
il ya eu un suivi super lent super
profond sur la personne pour vraiment
dire que c'est sûr parce que retarder
une puberté ça peut avoir quand même des
effets graves à long terme si je dis
quand même 18 ans tavi qui étaient
bloquées des plantes à vie mais une fin
la personne exactement ce que serait
devenu même star est [ __ ] de puberté
plus tard savais toi ça va avoir des
nerfs
mais normalement je te dirai que ceci
plus des jeunes plutôt comment ce jeune
plus le suivi beaucoup eu celle là mais
plus et c'est vraiment frustré pour être
justement de ne pas se tromper parce que
c'est quelque chose qui comme
irréversible s'arrêtent à mi temps je
pense que ça commence à 12-11 12 ans
peaufine 11
je sais plus dans le fond quand est-ce
qu'une puberté commence mais moi je
jouais au hockey et puis quand je
t'avais dit oui il y avait des gars pee
wee deuxième année que moi je t'ai pee
wee première année puis une note leur
puberté fini complètement puis moi ça
tout à ne pas passer en tête
j'ai ma puberté tort les y en avait qui
l'avait de bonheur de ses puits puis moi
je t'ai jamais d'aller dans douche ce
qui ce qu'il avait eu à 20 jours ci à
l'aide en douche pts et un enfant les
premiers points les premiers points j'ai
quand même appris ça à 12 ans j'avais
déjà vu des photos
en fait j'ai vu un vidéo corporelle
vraiment faciale mais je pense que c'est
important pour elle après ce que j'avais
mais je trouve que c'est important quand
même de le faire 6,5 que ces systèmes et
on sait ce que c'est ça moi je rêve mais
ce n'est pas le savoir je le savais mais
commencer puisque plutôt parce que ça
l'a tellement savez à quel point ça
change tout quand il fait sur 20 ans
avec les corses se différencient parce
qu'avant il pas grave c'est vraiment
tout ce qui change tout eu tous les
excès moi je trouve ça important
toi tu vois ça comme un ben j'ai
l'impression qu'au québec c'est vraiment
bien encore de répit si c'est bien
encadré bougeait peu près même avec ce
c'est juste qu'ils étaient ivres au côté
de la médaille qu'on
qu'on laisse pas un jeune décider si peu
spartatouille à laquelle 6,81 une
décision quand même
dans le fond on s'accorde pas mal de
très grandes décisions mineures s'est
vraiment mis leur jetant sous un train
pis
pis si ce sont des sommes importantes
pic à ce que je sais pas si aussi jeune
que soit ton cerveau profil développer
dessus tout la
petit toutes les peaux les connaissances
mais toutes les formations les
informations pièce qui était assez
formés pour formuler sa décision le jeu
s'est passé mais se retrouver ce
blizzard son garçon tozzi
comment sur moi ma main mais la méthode
pourquoi moi j'ai pas j'ai pas un vagin
comme ça pour moi c'est ce que c'est ce
que je veux c'est souriant noël est des
fois le cas des gens j'ai entendu du
tout le cas des enfants étaient comme et
quand est-ce qu'on que mon pénis vos
tombes et puis je vois être quand même
ma soeur ou comme ami zen
c'est sur cette île n'est simple tout
mais que la fin de ses supérieurs je
vais y penser car transparente sur et
pompeux à moins d'être un thé traite on
peut d'ailleurs être pas sa souffrance
au sérieux et il y en a beaucoup qui
sont comme ça y est mettons beaucoup de
caractéristiques qui sont de l'autre en
terme de timmins en fallait que je sais
pas moi une fille qui veut tout le temps
faire couper les cheveux cococo puis qui
monte tout plein de caractéristiques
masculines officiers seulement camaçari
perpignan
ça amène beaucoup de réflexion mais tu
penses et social questionne autre que
donc par la charge est énorme
c'est beaucoup de responsabilités c'est
sûr que des fois des problèmes des
baraques qui n'ont pas la force de
prendre cette responsabilité il aussitôt
pas qu'ils oublient un peu ce graveur
dames 1 puis ça c'est pas si ça peut
être fait plus tôt pour moi c'est
beaucoup plus net positif là
mais c'est sur pied il toujours la
question d excuse possible quelqu'un
changer d'idée ouvrir vienne où tout
peut y être autonome mais ça doit être
ado je sais que ça soit bien encadré
mais c'est en tout cas aucun spécialiste
de professionnels aucun spécialiste de
parfait il y en a qui peuvent se tromper
évidemment comme hey des enfants
intersexe keane et intersexe piqué le
médecin décide de a boy ça reste un
petit goût puis finalement c'est une
petite fille puis le lion fait une
opération pour ôter ces partis dans des
films et le plus tard sa cause des
problèmes d'il ya aucun spécialiste de
boeuf et puis aucun même si tabou et
consulté pendant des années ça peut
finalement même pour le cfa je pense que
c'est comme important d'être le plus de
primes de vos plusieurs personnes de
voir plusieurs spécialistes pour juste
tenir en un qui veut dire oui oui oui
c'est sûr ces deux lois anti deuxième
opinion c'est s'appuie le protocole de
la première personne l'a amené à l'autre
or qu'est ce que la personne n'a revu
voir commenté comme à métaux pour ma
région plastique j'avais besoin de voir
deux psychologues que le deuxième
psychologue voit tout ce que la première
a écrit jusqu'à la vue du scanner
pensent-ils de tout ça et après ça me
poser des questions aussi pour voir si
ça coordonnées pas que je pense que
c'est important de voir plusieurs
psychologues surtout plus jeunes demain
puis probablement que c'est sûr je sais
pas c'est quoi les caisses qui est il
faut qu est ce qu il faut pour lequel
les jeunes de même le problème en qui
est beaucoup plus des protocoles mais je
pense c'est vraiment important dans ton
qu il ya eu un consensus avec tous les
procédés qui te rencontrer ouais c'est
souvent à la botte doutes et les pottoks
bien ça facilite la décision ça peut
faciliter et oui c'est gabriel merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été là ces
smartphones pôle édition extrêmement
enrichissante
puis je suis sûr que beaucoup de monde
qui vont apprécier ton honnêteté et sa
franchise son ouverture merci merci à
vous fait plaisir
[Musique]